I put that almond milk in
mine dude almond
milk that's crazy man almond milk when
you think about it I can't believe that
they're milking
almonds
what you know I think about you know
they got vegans and vegari and all of
that you know or uh whatever these
people are whoever is you know from
vetnam or whatever but I don't you know
I want to be support but dude
there y'all are milking
almonds they have almond milk dude when
I first of all when I was young I
remember they had Almond Joy remember
Almond Joy almonds was having fun
almonds were just laying on coconut just
pouring they had chocolate all over
their bodies they had two of them on the
coconut they had a little Amigo up there
a little
almondo and then a couple years ago they
started having almond butter and I'm
like what oh dang what did they
do what did they do to deserve this they
beating them up and buttering them up
and you can picture it if you want in
your head and I don't like to picture
that kind of stuff but you could picture
it bunch of almonds getting just smashed
into each other and
buttered come
on and then now they got almond
milk now they have almond
milk can you even can you even imagine
that how are you going to milk an
almond and call yourself a decent person
who's doing
this I didn't even know almond had
glands where they get what are they
doing can you imagine getting up early
and getting a couple almond out and
putting a little bucket between them and
just being
nasty this is got
you know this has got to stop I don't
like a lot of the you know I don't know
man I don't know I mean I've done a I've
done a bunch of shady [__] okay I'll
admit that you know I've lied to people
and I've definitely I've buried a bunch
of people's [__] Furniture one time
and I lied to them about it but I've
never I've never done anything pervert
like that to a damn nut
so if you out there milking almonds why
don't you ask yourself who you
are I mean hell I'd rather eat I'd
rather have I'd rather eat meat and be a
regular human than be some just creepy
crawler out there just you know with his
fingers out just [__] warming his
fingers up searching an almond for a
damn gland come on very
sad very sad